check check chinese check baby chicken
check
chicken sausage chick hearn chick peas
check check please
chicks chicka doodle d
remember chickadees remember that
remember chickadees
it was a little uh like a breakfast
place
i don't know if they it was chickadees
and you go in there and they had um
you know they give you the menu and it
was
they would hand write the menus every
day
which i think is probably why they went
out of business i mean at that point
you're more of a
calligraphy shop or something
i mean they'd hang i don't know
they say home of the handwritten menu
that was their big ticket that was their
big
you know get you in the door deal
home at a handwritten menu
and then they hand write them and then i
don't know what happened
i don't know what happened there was a
fire or
something
something happened over there but
um
but anyway uh what's going on man not
much
chickadees that was it and i go over
there and get me a little breakfast
you know get me a cut of ham get me a
you know two uh
bird eggs two bird eggs and a cut of ham
for three dollars
i remember and sometimes they have sweet
sweet entrees that set on there
little bonus section on the menu it said
uh
sweet entrees and it'd have you to get
your little hot cake or uh
you know um what's that
food we won in the uh war um
french toast get you you know get you a
little
you know a savory item
get you something like that chickadees
it was called
and sometimes i when i missed school if
i would miss the school bus they had a
man that would take me to school
and his i don't remember his name but he
was just kind of a
kind of a mysterious looking man and he
might have had i don't know cancer or
something but
he had um his son was named mcdonald
and his son was named big donald even
though he was little and
and sometimes i would miss the bu and
his son i think it maybe even dropped
out of school but
i would miss the bus and the dad would
uh
take me to school in his car
and he drove a car that was it wasn't a
hearse but it was like
it seemed like a hearse you know like
they probably had ghosts in the trunk
kind of thing kind of vehicle
you know it was just i mean if you got
in a car accident in this car you were
gonna die
because it was just real long and black
and
i think it was a hor a hearse but they
had sawed off the back and made it into
a regular car
and um and that was big donald's daddy
and he would take me to school
when i would miss school or when i would
miss the bus
and um and sometimes he would come out
at first and he said you missed it i
said i don't know
and he said maybe wait a little while
and i would wait a little longer and he
knew it had already passed
he was just kind of uh
you know just getting me calibrated for
a
a life of i guess uncomforter of
you know uncertainty i don't know but
he'd come out another time did you miss
it i
you know i don't know i don't know if i
missed it i mean it's 9 a.m i've been
out here for an hour and 45 minutes
school started at 7 30.
i probably missed it i mean say well
just you know
it could show up so i sit there and wait
it start getting hot
have my little book bag on feel my books
heating up
feel my homework all hot
i didn't do my homework actually man i
just feel my books hot okay i'll be
honest with you but
and then you say all right come on i'll
take you and i think since his son had
dropped out of school since his boy had
given up on
you know knowledge or blanket knowledge
you know or uh governmental knowledge
really
education that they were you know that
it was his chance to still have that
moment with his son
um and we would ride we would ride in
the car
and i would try to you know practice it
look at my book look at my spelling and
and he would blow cigarette smoke over
at me he'd be smoking a pack of door
owls over there
and he would both windows up i mean i
think he had damn glued the window shut
because he loved all the smoke
he wanted all the smoke baby and he'd
blow that smoke on me and ask me to
spell a word
and i would just try to you know my face
was burning my eyes were burning i would
try to get that word out of me
you know
i in
i in uh c
what is it buddy what is it let me blow
that smoke on me
like i in c
o in
spell it boy and he'd yell at me spell
it boy
and he'd even call me his son's name too
sometime
spell it big donald spell it little
donald and he couldn't remember
sometimes if his son was named big
donald or little donald
when he blow the smoke on me
i in c o and
inconvenience and he didn't know he he
didn't know how to spell [ __ ]
so he would just kind of you know kind
of
oh there you go there you go
and then he'd let me flick his cigarette
he'd hand it over to me and let me flick
it onto the floor
and uh but anyway we'd stop at this
place called chickadees
and go in there home in a handwritten
menus and we'd get in there and
and i'd read them with it said on the
menu
and i would read him straight up what it
said on the menu and
i may i don't honestly man maybe that
man he might not even know what to read
and maybe this was his way of just kind
of connecting with
you know with an education he never got
fully
or partially even or semi-partially you
know
i don't know but chickadees i remember
and then they uh you know one thing one
guy the guy with the best penmanship
didn't come in or something he got in a
fight with his wife and then
uh and they didn't have a menu one day
we went in there and they didn't have a
menu
and nobody knew what to do the co you
know
the waiter just the waitress just
standing there with her arms in the air
and and the cook just [ __ ]
gave up you know just cracked a couple
eggs right into his damn mouth and just
walked out and
and i think they burned the place down
for insurance or in
yeah for insurance money but anyway
what else man let's get into the episode
brother gang you know
it good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you could watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one